das ist spektakulär und es passiert
heute diese außeneinsätze an der
internationalen raumstation iss habe es
in sich die fachleute der nasa sprechen
von dem schwierigsten projekt seit der
reparatur des weltraumteleskops hubble
konkret geht es um das magnet
spektrometer das dringend ein neues
kühlsystem benötigt und genau das wurde
in den vergangenen jahren an der rwth
aachen entwickelt und es gibt noch eine
weitere fortentwicklung klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und activity glocken nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen anfang november 2009 10 war
es soweit und neben vier tonnen
ausrüstung kam endlich auch das lang
erwartete kühlsystem für das
alpha-magnet-spektrometer ams-02 auf der
internationalen raumstation iss an
am vergangenen freitag dem 15 11 2009 10
hatten sich der italienische raumfahrer
luca promi tarnow und der us-amerikaner
andrew morgan zu dem einsatz aufgemacht
dieser weltraumspaziergang der alles
andere als ein entspannter spaziergang
war lief nach nasa-angaben aber höchst
erfolgreich und dauerte insgesamt sechs
stunden und 39 minuten konkret geht es
um den teilchendetektor ams 02 der schon
seit dem jahr 2011 in betrieb ist das
spektrometer ist ganze sieben tonnen
schwer und enorm wichtig für die
forschung bislang hat es bereits 140
milliarden teilchen der kosmischen
strahlung aufgezeichnet und das mit dato
unerreichte präzision
die daten sollen dazu beitragen endlich
die größten rätsel der physik zu lösen
zum beispiel darum die mysteriöse
materie antimaterie asymmetrie im
universum vor herrscht darüber hat man
ja hier bei klicks und science fiction
ausführlich berichtet aber auch hoch
energetische prozesse der milchstraße
können mithilfe des spektrometers
nachvollzogen werden
das entscheidende element von ams 02 ist
ein silizium spur detektor der die
flugbahn genau vermessen kann doch dabei
wird wärme produziert und so ist ein
geschlossener und konstanter
kühlkreislauf 1 0 grad celsius
unerlässlich doch das mittlerweile nur
noch drei der vier pumpen des
kühlsystems arbeiten wundert niemanden
ursprünglich war das ganze nämlich nur
auf eine betriebsdauer von drei jahren
ausgelegt
und diese inzwischen deutlich
überschritten deswegen soll das neue
kühlsystem an den start gebracht werden
das den betrieb der ams 02 bis zum jahr
2030 zuverlässig sicher und genau das
wurde in deutschland gebaut
genaugenommen an der rwth aachen wo ein
forschungsteam vier jahre lang an einem
neuen kühlsystem getüftelt hat es ist so
groß wie ein kühlschrank und etwa 200
kilogramm schwer
in den kommenden wochen soll das neue
kühlsystem bei bis zu vier weiteren
stundenlangen außeneinsätzen an dem
alpha-magnet-spektrometer ams-02
montiert werden eine super komplizierte
aufgabe denn dabei müssen in dem
detektor verbindungsleitung freigelegt
und durchtrennt werden die nur wenige
millimeter dick sind die dicken
handschuhe der astronauten machen das zu
einer äußerst komplizierten
angelegenheit denn die anderen sehr
empfindlichen komponenten in der
nachbarschaft dürfen dabei keineswegs in
mitleidenschaft gezogen werden die
europäische weltraumagentur esa spricht
von einem der anspruchsvollsten
weltraumspaziergängen seit der reparatur
des weltraumteleskops hubble
dazu der physiker stefan sell von der
rwth aachen man kann es mit einer
operation am offenen herzen vergleich
nahm es ist von der elektronik her
komplexer als die ganze restliche
raumstationen zusammen
doch mein erster weltraum spazieren ging
alles glatt und es konnten sogar schon
vorbereitungsarbeiten für den zweiten
einsatz durchgeführt werden der für
freitag also für heute geplant ist doch
nicht nur das kühlsystem sondern auch
spezialwerkzeug das für den austausch
der kühlleitung notwendig ist wurde in
deutschland produziert die nasa hatte es
zunächst in den usa in auftrag gegeben
die produktion war dort allerdings
gescheitert spätestens am 11
dezember soll das
alpha-magnet-spektrometer ams-02 auf der
iss wieder in betrieb gehen
die forschungsgruppe an der rwth aachen
tüftelt aber bereits an einer neuen
sache und zwar dem sogenannten ams 100
ab 2030 sollen dadurch die
präzisionsmessungen mit 1000 fach
erhöhter sensitivität ermöglicht werden
müllentsorgung im allein nicht ganz
unaufwendig es vorhaben also anklicken
anschauen und hyperraum tv abonnieren
super fundierter kanal bei uns dem
science network eson 1054 bis dann
bleibt dran